et on commande se fasse thème gossip
avec la chanteuse rihanna camorra qui
auraient été victimes de violences
conjugales de la part de son
ex-compagnon niska l'interprète du titre
réseau c'est le blogueur aquabike qui a
révélé cette info sur internet la
semaine dernière information qui ont été
confirmés par la chanteuse en message
privé à un de ses abonnés des photos
diana camorra le visage tuméfié circule
sur internet
à l'heure actuelle ni ce cas n'a pas
répondu publiquement à ces accusations
johnny hallyday continue d'être l'un des
rois de la musique et ce ne sont pas les
ventes de ses disques qui prouve le
contraire avec 2,7 millions d'albums
écoulés depuis sa disparition dont 1,7
millions uniquement pour son dernier
album le taulier aurait rapporté à ses
héritiers la coquette somme de 7
millions d'euros
reste à savoir qui touchera cet argent
alors que les rumeurs vont bon train
autour de la naissance du bébé du couple
que forme le prince harry et meghan
markle celle de l'arrivée des jumeaux et
plus insistante que les autres et ce
n'est pas cette petite phrase du prince
harry lors d'une réception à buckingham
palace qui calmera les journalistes
qu'en effet ce dernier aurait répondu à
un invité qui lui disait qu'avec un
enfant il fallait s'habituer aux nuits
blanches
surtout s'il y en a deux une petite
plaisanterie que de nombreux
britanniques prennent pour une
révélation réponse fin avril
décidément dans le clan kardashian le
succès est héréditaire
khalid génère la plus jeune fille de la
famille vient d'entrer dans l'histoire
en étant sacrée à seulement 21 ans
milliardaire la plus jeune au monde elle
pulvérise ainsi de deux ans le record
détenu par marc zuckerberg le créateur
de facebook
cet argent provient en grande partie de
kayl cosmetics la société de produits de
beauté qu'elle a lancée il ya trois ans
c'est samedi soir dernier que la
rappeuse star nicki minaj était attendu
à bordeaux pour un concert exceptionnel
un show qui a dû être annulée au dernier
moment alors que le public était déjà
dans la salle
à l'origine de cette annulation des soi
disant problème technique
[Applaudissements]
alors qu'elle a passé le reste de sa
soirée à la foire de bordeaux
vu l'ampleur de la polémique elle a fini
par s'adresser directement à ses fans
par vidéo sur son compte instagram
assure que ses fans français lui
pardonne de sitôt et enfin selon le
magazine public la star de téléréalité
nabila serait enceinte d'un enfant de
son compagnon thomas vergara si elle
n'annonce pas la nouvelle elle même sur
les réseaux la jeune femme ne dément pas
les nombreuses rumeurs qui circulent
autour de cet événement une nouvelle qui
intervient peu de temps après l'annoncé
de leur mariage kanak est là pour vous
avez retenu un de plus witherell hamas
et nicki minaj concert annulé je trouve
que c'est une telle désinvolture par
rapport à ses fans et son public même si
c'est vrai même si sa cause de problèmes
techniques la façon dont elle l'a dit
est inqualifiable ses traits je m'en
fous titre moi je venais d'un artiste
qui avait annulé vraiment je vous le dis
une tournée parce qu'il était vraiment
sous terre ils étaient en rade sera
totale
c'est nabila elle est enceinte et je
peux vous le confirmer c'est vrai nom de
toi d'où tu peux confirmer toit à un
prix non mais alors bref c'est une info
est vraiment enceinte the rock l'a
confirmé c'est une source vrai que c'est
confiance n'est pas elle mais c'est
facile c'est à dire pour thomas yale
voilà oui je suis enchantée sont ravis
et l'enfant va être magnifique et de
l'enfant oui oui moi c'est sur aion
nakamura
je ne sais pas si l'information est
exacte parce que elle elle dit oui sans
dire oui vraiment mais ça permet tout
simplement de remettre en lumière encore
ce problème que sont les violences
conjugales et de dire que ça ne l'est
pas dans un milieu et un seul et que ça
peut malheureusement avoir lieu dans
tous les milieux sociaux et je rappelle
quand même que depuis janvier bien
trente femmes qui sont mortes sous les
coups de leur compagnon
donc c'est l'occasion de leur dire oui
mais il faut pas il faut pas en parler
sur les réseaux sociaux
arte plein puis isolé